welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Godzilla times Kong is it
Godzilla X Kong Godzilla Godzilla and
[Music]
[Applause]
monkey the first trailer is now out and
throughout this video we're going to be
going through everything that you need
to know about the film this includes
what we see happening in the teaser and
also some of the rumors around the film
about which monsters could be showing up
some spoilers are ahead we won't ruin
the end but if you want to go into the
film without knowing anything then I
highly recommend you turn off now if you
enjoy it then make sure you subscribe
cuz we release videos every week Fit For
A King Kong and without the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the
trailer
for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only
exist on the surface of our
planet what else were we wrong
about welcome to my
world you come on
in this world has more
secrets than we could possibly imagine
Miracles
I
still now and
then
what is
that that's not
Kong what could have done this okay so
the movie is obviously set after the
events of Godzilla versus Kong with Gman
further being something we as humans
Embrace according to the rumors on
Reddit he'll remain as a protector that
takes down some of the bigger Titan
threats out there this includes a Titan
called a renade who sort of in line with
a spider types that we've seen
throughout the films the Titan comes
from the hollow Earth which at the
moment is where Kong's located
Godzilla's meant to tear this apart
during the opening scene of the movie
and then apparently he hibernates in the
Rome Coliseum now while this is going on
Kong's ruling over his domain with him
inadvertently Awakening an evil ape
tribe that was trapped deep down there
you might remember him coming across
statues of these creatures during the
prior film and this movie will be about
Kong becoming King that scene most
notably in the new poster which has the
words b or new king over the week we got
posters for both Godzilla and Kong and
thus this whittles sit down to having to
be the scar king bow to your new king
man's clearly trying to take over and
this giant red ape's going to cause a
lot of problems the new king could also
be what the Empire refers to with its
centering around this evil group of apes
this is someone who was shown in the
original teaser and the toil leaks they
pretty much spoiled at all I love them
but they spoil it all now in those he
was carrying a giant spear with looks
like a titanox type creature's skull on
it the name the scar King I think also
has a deeper layer to it as at the
moment Kong still called Kong I'm
wondering this right and it's a the time
the time I'm wondering the time sorry
sometimes you have to let it play out
and no I'm wondering you right I'm
wondering if Kong will finally get the
King Kong name which in itself ties him
with the poster I feel like Kong might
be the one who gets crowned in the end
though and that could also time within a
monarch monarch of course itself derives
from royalty and maybe they'll crown him
or something in the movie Just a theory
yeah just want to make that clear but
the red hand there that of course ties
in with the other films a red hand print
appeared in verses as well and it's
constantly popped up throughout the
other Kong movies now this was something
Kong put his own Palm on and as I've
been saying it's all connected it's
clear that the movie's marketing is
leading heavily into that too as both
the Instagram account and posters have
iconography of it on Instagram earlier
in the week we had nine posts in total
and in the end this laid it all out the
first set was the handprint from the
versus movie with something is coming
making up the next this all came off the
back of the hand from Skull Island with
the poster getting this put across in
the logo too also I watched Kong Skull
Island the other day and they had both
Casey and Loki in it it was nice little
Marvel team they've also got Captain
Marvel and Nick Fury as well so yeah bit
of trivia for you there now inside the
chamber Kong sat on the throne which is
murdering the scar King who does the
same thing apparently he wants to take
over the surface this world and create
what's going to be the titula new Empire
anyway at this point them coming forward
makes Godzilla awaken and this ties back
into that prior movie during a Kong's
main weapon was an axe with his dorsal
fin which was a big mysterious point of
that movie we're going to learn exactly
what happened here and it'll be Godzilla
that traps Scar in The Hollow Earth this
explains how he found the weapon and why
all of Kong's species were cleared out
from here still though you know that
Kong's going to carry it and along with
him the other characters are going to be
getting upgrades too Kongs is going to
be in the form of a metal arm don't know
how big that will be in real life how
long that took to build but yeah the
guy's going to be carrying a gauntlet
that kind of reminds me of the one that
that comes up from the MCU I am a bit
obsessed with the MCU but you know he's
just going to be smacking people about
and knocking their teeth out the
evolutions also include Godzilla and
yesterday R confirmed that there will be
a point in which he evolves we've course
see that happening in the trailer and we
get a big moment where he's clearly
hibernating behind an ice structure this
fills up with a classic blue and it acts
almost like a cocoon he pops forward
like a like a beautiful butterfly and we
can see him in All His glory looks
incredible they've changed the color of
his Dorsal fins but man's clearly
rocking alongside Kong and just waiting
to take people out either way I am
thinking Gman may be beaten badly and
then have to take this next step to get
ready for the final battle now scar King
will be amongst those that were trapped
and because of this he's going to hold a
grudge against Godzilla from what's been
dug up due to the toy leaks and info
that we have on the film he's also going
to command a Titan called shimu shimu is
going to be designated as the first
Titan who in the past brought about the
first ice age shimu has a nice freezing
breath and man needs to chill when it
comes to destroying the planet now he's
probably going to be what the g dog
fights Raz Kong will likely go Toe totoe
with scaring there's also his army to
contend with too so I think there's
going to be lots of major fights in the
movie now my wife yeah she told me Size
Doesn't Matter but I've still been
Googling a lot to to see if it does what
I found right and I found this on a
website is that there's actually a size
comparison for all the different
monsters what were you thinking I was
talking about now you can see scaring
and shimu greatly dwarf Godzilla and
Kong and I think it's going to be a big
thing for the film still though the
little guy my wife says the little guy
can still pack a punch and it's not how
big the hammer is it's about how hard
you hit the nail with it s now if
you're somehow enjoying the video and
want to help support the Channel then
please click the join button just below
the video right now we've got a
50-minute breakdown of Apocalypse Now
which of course greatly inspired Kong
Skull Island we drop videos and audio
versions of breakdowns all the time as
early as we can and huge thank you to
everyone who supported us as it
massively helps us out really appreciate
it now these movies wouldn't be anything
without the human elements and we'll
once more see Rebecca Hall's character
Eileen Andrews she'll again be caring
for Gia who still has a strong
relationship with Kong and her ANC says
the EO will also be explored too they're
going to be joined by Dan Stevens who we
know from the cast list will be called
Steven Randa he's described as being a
bit like a nerd and a weirdo probably
one of my subscribers not not not you
mate I'm not talking about you oh what
do you expect you're my number one
customer and also Chang the subject
quickly look at look at E's hair out
here looking like Fast and Furious but
out here looking like she's about to
kill some Fantastic
Beasts Brian Tyreek Henry will also
attend to but unfortunately we're going
to be losing some main states that
includes Millie Bobby Brown's medicon
and her dad Kyle Chandler's mock
according to the leaks the movie
actually has a really strong human
element in it which we're going to have
to say mate to be honest I've never out
and out hated this stuff but it's always
clear what it is we come for that is of
course godzill and Kong and the pair
will also be having a rematch in the
film that's going to be going down in
egyp with shimu ala being there too I
think this might be when he beats
Godzilla and thus he has to to go to the
point that he has to evolve now Chris
from 3C films has been talking about how
the early name for the movie was son of
Kong and we do meet what I think that is
this is clearly a character that comes
from the hollow Earth and perap perap
perap they renamed it because they
wanted to give some Focus to Godzilla
he's obviously the big name and I am
kind of sad that we didn't see Kong
smashing those hairy cheeks yes I would
have love to see that happening in the
movie I'm a bit like Dan Stevens myself
so me and you we we're sort of the same
aren't we nah just kidding I'm not not a
loser like you M you sucker got you in
the end see you chump now on top of this
we also have some Easter egg that called
back to the prior movies namely that
first Godzilla from 2016 the opening of
the trailer sounds like it's got that
2001 Space Odyssey music accompanying it
and it is a really atmospheric way to
start off this whole
thing
Kong can't stop this on his
own he won't be
[Music]
alone
welcome to my
world
is that a mini
Kong and that wraps up the teaser and I
can't think of a better time that
there's been to be a Godzilla fan not
only have we got this coming out but
we've also got Monarch and apple plus
right now which is exploring this
universe also I left out Kong in that
previous sentence um I like Kong as well
and if you're a Kong fan it's a great
time too now Mt has been doing weekly
breakdowns of Monarch and I definitely
recommend that you go and check them out
me I've just love being an unluer and
seeing it unfold and it's been a slow
and steady burn just setting up what's
to come if I missed any Easter eggs in
this video though tie directly into that
then please let me know cuz I've not
been viewing it on a crazy Easter egg
type analysis thing where I watch it
three or four times so yeah thank you
for doing my job for me I'm much
appreciated and uh We've also of course
got Godzilla minus one which I've been
told is one of the best films since the
original that's coming out in England
very very soon and I've actually got
tickets to see it early so I'm very
excited for that now as with this it
looks like a bang hat and I'm actually
surprised at how much they're building
off the last film I did kind of feel
they sort of fumbled the ball a bit with
Kong's Axe and at the time though he
should have been the one to take the
dorsal fin and craft it with this though
and all the handprints lay throughout
the Saga I actually feel that it pays
off better now it's all making a lot
more sense and I think there's a lot of
really cool things that they can now do
with this movie I really don't know
where things are going to go from here
but I have to say this teaser makes me
think they could be building up things
to a really cool Direction I did have
some issues with the last movie and you
could kind of tell it being cut down
quite a bit still though I thought there
was a lot to like and the rumors that
they've been given a lot more room to
breathe on this film I think that's
something that should be the case and it
feels like we've subtly had this movie's
villain hinted at in a lot of other
films I really think that's some
top-notch storytelling and I'm excited
to see what the film builds upon please
drop a like on the video if you've
enjoyed it and again if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button if you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one house the
dragon stuff Marvel te's and a lot more
we drop new designs on there all the
time too so definitely keep an eye out
and thanks for your support now if you
want something else to watch we've got a
monarch breakdown on screen right now
where MTN covers all the details and
things you need to know definitely head
over there right after this without the
way huge thank you for sting through the
video I've been your host Paul and I'll
see you in the next one take care
is